I've brought the person I know who can
probably relate the most to what we're
about to watch Alyssa be crazy let me
say you whatever I'm sorry I'm sorry you
concerned Alyssa be crazy my neighbor
lives with her hubby Dan they are both
major gamers and they have tempers so
we're gonna watch today ultimate gamer
rage compilation number two have you
ever seen any of these compilations
they're hilarious but I dunno game very
well I bet you do guys go check out
Alyssa be crazies twitch where she does
what again I do a lot of variety so a
lot of games and I also do a lot of art
for our Commission's on there as well
very good let's do this
[Music]
oh oh oh I kind of like I just yeah I
just get TT and I can't even move down
on that site
yeah you got to tear you got to go close
by it's blitz you can't stay back
and I'm getting beat down my [ __ ]
dude jumped into a mob and gets mattify
dude this is way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's easy to agent I guess I imagine how
does this keep killing everybody it's
about to go down
that's so mad I brought the only
controller I have oh this is why I don't
go over to your place precursor to
oh this is more sad than anything the
easy path easy 9 Jesus feel hot the guns
in it him Baylor Purefoods buzz in
without doing speed imagine this is the
only time I watch the video where I
don't need subtitles for a foreign
language rage is a universal language
guys it's just a game
yeah I'm having fun what a great game oh
no it's way too high up on there oh
[Music]
really shame 4head those probably their
parents TV's you yeah
god it's so much money
that's like this here I don't understand
it's a game you're gonna have bad game
like not everyone's asleep on the soup
is oh there we go foreign language
[Music]
[Music]
Wow me that Jesus here we go
it's like marbles with cars yeah that's
what it is
[Laughter]
why do you play games that make you that
angry it's an addiction man I mean he
could take a break this is why I don't
buy mad and kid oh and that was an
expensive controller my boyfriend and I
broke up Ross shot OOP right up in the
crotch oh no oh that hurts
no way game on your phone come on this
guy does not take care of his lifestyle
watching me like we just tap tap game to
gosh I know right oh dude you know you
probably wouldn't rage out right now if
you just play the bedroom I hope your
phone broke I think that's fake that is
like real are the big cameras right
there I mean maybe he was streaming some
people scream from their phones oh okay
just saw these guys in an Instagram
video yeah music makes it better that's
gonna go into heavy metal yeah it's
really hard yeah it's um she's people
make their own Mario levels first video
stuff to like yes yeah
to try to feed that's more that's more
your husband here's my proposition yes
come over and play Mario maker on stream
with us that'd be fun cuz you know Mario
I know you know Mario who doesn't know
Mario dream because the people like you
guys could make your own levels send us
the code you could play it it is that
region oozing place Dan spent I think he
spent something like 16 straight hours
left you're trying to beat a Ross level
who is game grumps Ross that's why you
guys live in a mess up the joke studio
apartment that's what I was gonna say I
was it's a studio apartment I was gonna
imply that they're really poor they
don't because they just spend all this
time playing games that are working but
then I mess up the joke and no they
don't have a studio apartment okay it's
gone now I've got I'm pretty pissed off
at games before you know what else gets
really pissed off my girlfriend Olivia
Toby times where I'm just
like watch along own TV show reactions
for patreon I'll just see her just start
cussing up a storm the other girl in the
living room John I salute each other
like playing God war now I've never seen
you or danrage am I gonna lie I could
really see Dan losing like ballistic
about something man yeah he can lose it
it's very easy to trigger him if you
know what you're doing with your games
like where to put him what to make a
play right right for me the only game
that really triggers me really really
hard sometimes Final Fantasy 14 but only
when I'm doing duties I feel like I'd
never seen that game and one of these
compilations triggering someone to that
point duties can just be very rage
inducing to small amounts I don't know
why they triggered me so hard like
that's the thing is like they're not
especially hard or anything they're just
frustrating and that's what gets me you
know sometimes what I do duties I rage -
[Music]
that's why you move next door to me yeah
sure can accommodate your provide some
highbrow humor there was a time where
this probably might not have made any
sense to me that people would react this
way to games but I know what it's like
to just not beat a level and how
infuriating that is it for some reason
you just don't quit and I think that's
what the breaking point is you just kind
of get to a point where you can't just
go alright alright you're there you
gotta like you gotta play and the only
thing gets you away from it is going
that's the other thing gets you to break
away from it I get it but I always think
of dollar signs whenever I watch these
I'm just like that's it's like 50 bucks
right there here zero that's like $200
it's so
that's tough man like look it's a game
you're playing more than likely you own
this game you're gonna be coming back to
it so either you can get up take a
breather leave come back keep playing
right you could do that
leave go spend more money on the thing
you just had that you ruined to keep
playing the same game yes like well we
need to have an intervention with your
husband
I see sometimes like there's let's
player so I think like kind of play it
up a little bit and I enjoy it like
markiplier I think sometimes when
markiplier rages he's knows he's doing
it for entertainment
sometimes I'm sure it's very real there
are times we get to is playing up some
of these I'm like kind of questionable
about but for the most part a lot is
like very real who this is I would not
want to be friends with this guy yeah
take a deep breath drink some water
maybe happen right and there are some
people I meet who are the nicest human
beings and then you play like a board
game with them video game and suddenly
there's is insanely competitive side
that just comes at it I have a friend
like that at number years that's what
brings the weirdest games I think I'm
not play just do anyone can get there if
you're playing I game for too long you
get so fire you oh I love monopoly we
should play Monopoly together I do love
monopoly it's great well we'll record
that live stream it'll be a total blast
all right guys we'll keep a look out for
that one make sure checking Alyssa be
crazy to its channel thank you to gaming
compilations for putting this together
subscribe to them as soon as you can
subscribe already jet